so will China pull us out the economic
crisis I think it's going to help the
stimulus package of the size of the
stimulus package in China is huge I
don't think given that America is still
twenty five percent of the world's
economy Europe is another twenty-five
percent the world's economy I don't
think China on its own he's going to
pull the world out there comic crisis I
don't think it's big enough here it will
probably be the biggest economy in the
world in about 20 years time but I don't
think there's enough oomph in the
Chinese economy to pull the world out
research really America in Europe I've
got to turn around and China can't do it
alone you can't pull this wagon just on
its own